valuing them meant disrespecting
yourself would you still carry on doing
it you think that's what it is because
we live in a world full of girls that
put their ass and titties on the
internet every day I am the first one if
I'm valuing
yeah so what you're saying is absolute
you weren't in love with that
man you value yourself your sex worker
let's call it straight
to myself I Leave You for Cheating
you're a sex worker I will admit I
stopped doing it while I was with him
because he out to her and I tried too
but then I went back to it because
because I can't get enough of it and I
don't mean it to disrespect you
don't get enough of it oh yeah no does
it work yeah in a professional sense or
like yeah it's fulfilling literally yeah